good morning
Millennials welcome back to the toast I
am thrilled I am excited I'm a little
scared really you like to me are a like
an anomaly like you really you're very
intimidating that is the nicest thing
anyone has ever said to me I really appr
nice that's so funny that's really sweet
it's Jackie Shimmel I've replaced Jackie
ashre with Jackie Shimmel I'm feeling
very comfortable very excited a toast
virgin I am and let me tell you my
girlfriends are very excited about this
oh yeah I've got some toasty toasty
girls I love that yeah they're very
excited you're kind of like the reigning
LA Queen of podcasting so I think I'm
the self-titled New York queen of
podcasting 1% so it's nice to kind of
have a by Coastal moment and you know
what's really fun about us is that I
feel like people in those sad toxic
Facebook groups have pitted us against
each other for years and always thought
that we had beef like I've heard that
before Oh I was talking I was on Taylor
Sher show and she was talking about how
people thought you had beef with Taylor
ster right yeah I loved that so much I
love Taylor ster me too I love
her well we don't have beef we've only
met one time oh my god when we spent
that weekend together which was fabulous
it was I mean maybe fabulous for you
it's very triggering for me okay that
influencer Retreat my one and only
influencer Retreat I was really only
invited because I think that I was like
a conduit for other more influential
people to come that's interesting I was
only invited literally the day before
someone must have dropped out someone
dropped out were like do you want to go
to LA tomorrow I'm like no they're like
well you're being paid I'm like I'll be
there let me know when 100% let's go so
I got like Heather there I got Heather
McMahon there and then I got Morgan
Stewart there so you were very much like
the like the communications person yes
and I had the worst room in the whole
spot oh my lit that's funny it's true it
was like by the custodial closet and you
know part of the thing when you go there
is you're supposed to you know tag the
brand and all the things I had never
done this before I was kicked off
Instagram three hours into that weekend
Oh I do remember that for calling you
and Morgan and Heather McMahon
whes yes you know what it's coming back
to me now I will say I know there are a
lot of um like influencer trips that
happened to be a particularly fabulous
one that was die for it was at the nou
hotel in Malibu which is like this
gorgeous like 12 room Hotel invite only
I stayed in a closet yes the toilets
were Toto I was really hung over and I
threw up in the Toto did you we had like
a private dinner at noou it was really
fabulous so fun and a fabulous group
like you said Morgan Stewart Heather me
and you Lauren Elizabeth like it was a
gorgeous crew it was a gorgeous crew so
it was the first time we met yeah and
then we like became Instagram friends
but we haven't met or hung out since
then so when I was coming to La I was
like I got to get that on the
podcast oh I'm so glad you did we have
so much in common I think so too let me
tell you why we both we both like not
ironically released music totally I mean
I was like semi ironically but that's
okay mine was completely serious which
is incredibly
sad that is to die for I do do you love
to sing no I mean I'm a terrible singer
but I just thought it would be funny you
know Peak Corona virus lockdown living
for nothing why don't I drop a pop song
like to me I look at your life and I
would do anything to be married to
someone who's like a professional music
producer right that's his job title yes
and he like has a full-blown like music
studio I you would never get me out of
that studio I would make my husband make
me songs like I it would be 24/7
non-stop but like the problem with my
husband is that he won't oh like he is
so intimidated by my musical prowess
that's understandable that I mean I have
begged really begged I think I'm
dropping a Hanukkah Bop this year I love
that idea let me know if you need a
feature I will literally come to your
house perfect fly to La I will do it
100% like a rap feature or like a I
don't give a like I just I whenever
I do like um shows I do comedy shows and
I'm about to go on stage every single
time I think to myself I would so much
rather be on the stage for singing like
I love to sing oh my God see I don't
love to sing but I love the idea of
being a pop star and I feel like I would
sell the out of it you
would am I allowed to cuss on here it is
encouraged thank God I mean do you curse
on your podcast no never yes every other
word is it's terrible so funny so I
feel like we have a lot in common our
love of Music yes name being Jackie like
I just feel in like a kindred spirit
sisterly yeah and you just had a baby
and I obviously don't have any children
but I like do you want mine no he's kind
of cute but Anno but I like appropriate
mom culture because I I literally think
I know everything about motherhood
because of Jackie and my sister Olivia
you probably do no I know I know more
than the average woman who doesn't have
children okay and so you're fresh fresh
out of uh motherhood child birth how you
doing I'm okay I'm doing good yesterday
we had a beautiful day together
the day um we did do a drive of the
local orphanage in calabases I know
exactly where it is and I'm thinking
about getting like the Google Maps from
our house to the orphanage framed
Gallery wall as a reminder in his
Nursery because there are days where I'm
like I severely regret this decision
really yeah if I'm being honest I know
that's I I have like a a very
complicated thought process and
relationship having I definitely want to
have children it's just like a matter of
when not if and lot of anxiety about it
especially about the pregnancy so I know
you had like a similar Journey so
hearing you being refreshingly honest is
really it's comforting it is I will tell
you I was so petrified of being pregnant
like more so than anything in the entire
world I could think of yeah and I don't
know but mine was really lovely like I
almost I regret saying this um enjoyed
it no that like to me makes me sick cuz
to me you're like similar to me in an AR
extreme thoughts on it so to hear you
say that brings enormous Comfort to
someone like me for real and I think
maybe a lot of people listening who are
at the same age where it's like they're
married and you know they know they want
to have kids but like right now I don't
know I know I felt that way I'm like
What's the rush like my life is
awesome and then I was just prolonging
it prolonging it and finally one month I
decided to plate that bastard and then
boom here we are here we are mother of
the year and your son's name is Clyde
which is so cute and different I love
Jackie's obsessed with like baby names
especially for boys it's very hard so
hard what's the meaning well we didn't
have one at the beginning we just like
kind of thought it was cute and then we
found out that it was a family name and
a famous lion tamer's name which is like
feels very Leo Leo adjacent and his
middle name is lion Clyde lion oh that's
so nice kind of rock Starry motherhood
really does suit you you think I do you
should see me out in the wild with the
kid you wouldn't say that I'm like can
you please and I'm like burping him and
his like limbs are flailing everywhere
and he can't lift his head up not a big
tummy time gal working on it oh tummy
time is Warfare I like when I see it I'm
like this is brutal it's a neglect like
it's so sad feels so wrong and I just it
does I just avoid it at all costs so
he's kind of like wobbly in the neck but
we're getting there he'll figure it out
yeah I think so you're a working mom you
are so busy and you were still gracious
enough to bring me a gift here today yes
and I mean it's a gift but it's also a
threat kind of here's the thing I want
to be very clear on your platform that I
am not an airan girly like I am not
someone it's not part of my like genetic
makeup it's not a personality trait for
me it's just convenient I'm a Suburban
airwan girl that's very different than
the West Hollywood airwan girls you know
uh I get in I like the buffalo
cauliflower Sumi so I watch your
Instagram stories and you're always
eating in your car I love it and that's
what you're eating sometimes I would say
once to twice a week you will find me at
the Calabasas airwan sitting in the
parking lot eating by myself I saw
Beverly Mitchell there this morning wow
seventh heaven Queens you don't
understand I started like my eyes
started twitching and I started full
body sweats and I was just patrolling
the aisles with our smoothies trying to
make eye contact she could have a
restraining order against me deep
fixation with Mitchell I have a deep
fixation on 7th Heaven like that show
was so toxic was not okay in any way and
one of my favorite ticktockers his name
is Rob he watches old episodes and then
does like a two-minute recap of how
insane there's an episode where Jessica
Beal gets hooked up God bless her she
gets like addicted to like Natural
Health supplements that give her energy
and she's on the basketball team and
she's like up at 6:00 a.m. like
basketball till 6 p.m. just like
sweating out on the court on drugs
they're acting like she's literally
doing blow and all the um the pastor dad
has to like sit her down and take her to
rehab it's so stupid I think I need to
start seventh heaven over again I think
you do cuz I missed it I think you do
but you watch it as a kid
here and there I was more of a Melrose
Place girl oh interesting I was
definitely more of a seventh heaven even
though like I grew up in like a deeply
proud Jewish Family like we were all
watching 7 heaven you well it probably
only reinforced the Judaism totally it
was it was honestly a show that showed
showcased allyit but it's sure
form no I just I love Beverly Mitchell I
don't know why I'm so happy for you she
has like this beautifully jovial broken
energy on Instagram there's an innocence
there but also a Darkness 100% she was
on Seventh Heaven so I know it's only
right she just counts down those days
till Jessica be's birthday as someone
who lives in LA and like a a cool
neighborhood do you see a lot of
celebrities I do you do yeah I mean I
live in Kardashian land essentially so
there is a lot of Kardashian run-ins I
mean Beverly Mitchell for me tops the
tier celebrity run-ins but I wouldn't
say that I'm yeah I'm not like a mover
and a shaker like that right you're
definitely not the type of person
to like go up and ask someone for a
photo I you're not Claudia I would never
although I would stalk Beverly Mitchell
at airwan if I had more time traffic was
building I would have followed her I
know you would through every
aisle and I did wait outside on the curb
just to see cuz I knew that white Yukon
was hers I could feel it did you take a
photo like a stalker photo lurking in
the back or no photos no I did for sure
okay you'll show me later yeah I'll show
you later I was like oh my God Beverly
Mitchell's here Beverly Mitch here but
like foaming up the M that's huge it's a
really big deal for me I could cry no
you could do a whole podcast episode
about it I will so you went to aan for
yourself and you're gracious enough to
be like hey dirty I'm going to Aran do
you want anything not knowing I had
never been it's so not me like
everything I stand for is the antithesis
of air Hanan you know my favorite thing
about you thus far is that when we were
at said vital proteins oh I do free
plugs but there you go when we were at
the um influencer retreat they were
really Hawk and Wellness supplements
green juice and we were not there for
that no we ordered McDonald's from
across the street fun fact there is a
McDonald's across the street from this
like number one hotel in the entire
world yeah a beachfront McDonald's we
ordered it and the staff at the noou
hotel was kind enough to Plate it for us
but you spearheaded the movement I mean
of I'm a human being like I need to eat
how the did we get chicken nuggets
on a plate on a plate and a Diet Coke in
a glass in a glass at this noou
hotel listen I was a woman with a dream
and you saw it through and I just I
can't thank you enough so you've brought
me here a smoothie so aroan is like a
grocery store here in La for those who
don't know and they're known for like
their like juice bar kind of all of the
things the smoothies are probably the
main focus main you know the $300 stupid
ass smoothies how much was this I'll VMO
you never um I believe it was
$19 I don't believe you which is
probably on the that's like the medium
level price of an Awan smoothie I
ordered one one time I started doing
substitutes they're like it's $32 I'm
like you can go yourself is this
considered like a meal replacement I
don't think so people in La really need
to get a grip like a $20 so and what's
it you told me this is so they do like
celebrity collabs all the time Hy Bieber
has one this is the haly Bieber one that
is the Haley Bieber smoothie I have not
personally tried this one so you're kind
strawberries strawberry Beres there's
like a coconut Cloud thing collagen I
have no idea breast milk no literally
probably all right I'm going to try it
and this is absolutely not a statement
on haly Bieber herself no no it's just
we all know I don't really like eat
stuff like this so let's
go okay tasting notes no it's not as bad
as I thought it would be okay but in no
universe is this good okay in no
universe is this worth $19 let Al alone
$1 wa why is it too sweet is it not
sweet enough so like milky I feel like
I'm like sucking on an uter I don't like
that it's really
um it's weird is it like
milkshake adjacent I if it was milkshake
adjacent it'd be finished okay it's
gross like I I really can't describe let
me take one more but also let me say it
does taste like strawberries oh well I
would hope
so you know like it is growing on
me I don't know what if it's the taste
that's going on me or just like the
label like I'm just an aan girly I'm
skinny I mean you look cute yeah know
with like my nude Ensemble my Chanel
shoes my Aran you can't tell me
right now no you can't so while I'm not
loving the taste I am loving the sense
of superiority it brings upon yeah do
you feel like a veil has just been like
lifted and you're just lighter and it's
giving like holier than thou energy like
I'm better than everyone because I eat
Aran I'm intimidated by you holding your
aan smoothie without the aan
Smoothie there's nothing even remotely
intimidated dating about disagree
Claudia disagree I think that um when I
was fat
there there's no other way to put it um
I think that people were more
intimidated by me I think that's like a
thing people feel that like you're like
aggressive I am so
non-confrontational I'm lovely lovely I
think I am I really am but I do people
do tell me I'm like scary but I'm really
not no I mean I feel that way about
myself I say all the time I'm lowkey
lovely and nobody believes it but if I
keep saying it I hope it's true but do
you really believe it yes you are lovely
but you are scary that's so nice I think
it's a good thing that means like you're
accomplished or just like an evil
well potentially yes potentially but
we'll see I don't think so so you're
going to join me today for the past five
stories can't wait what are you
currently like fixating on in pop
culture I know you love Bravo are you
watching new Housewives of New York I am
I am as well now I'm I'm disgruntled as
a viewer so I live for vintage Rooney
like there is nothing better in the
universe agree than vintage roony and I
think that like in the past few years we
all decided that these women need to be
our role models and like beacons of the
community yeah and that's not why we
watch The Real Housewives very true we
want them broken damaged toxic drinking
no that's so fair and it's not lovely
but it is true yeah no I was definitely
critical of like the fin seasons of the
OG because it was just everyone drinking
so much having these blowout fights and
not remembering it the next morning so
it was hard to follow that's true yeah I
live for like the golden years of roony
like the early Seasons I like is that a
buffalo coming down the stairs oh Alex
mcord I think about her and her Rosa
flareups every single day of my life I
think about her and her new found
happiness and life in Australia as a
psychologist I think about to me that is
proof that like you can come out of
anything totally and if Alex McCord was
on real housewi of New York right now
and all of this was happening she would
have been the cool like they wouldn't
have been able to get away with what
they got away with they literally just
disliked her immediately because she
lived in Brooklyn and had like
unrenovated baseboards well I I think it
was a little bit more than unrenovated
her and her family were like we're
living in a war zone it was insane
during Co I remembered that and then
during Co I went back and rewatched real
house in New York and the townhouse was
worse than I remembered like it was and
when Jill goes to visit and she sees how
they're living for the first time like
she's horrified horrified and bunk beds
with like this the plastic storage bins
under the bunk beds with all their
clothing and then the grand reveal of
the like Mulan Rouge like red crushed
velvet like black I'm like what the
happened and we we actually do have a
lot in common with Simon van campen
because he too released a song I know I
am real he is real and those he was real
for that red pants think about
him every single day so in the terms of
the new Ron like what's your general
take I'm two episodes behind but I'm
pretty I'm I'm in the no I've done a
full 180 on Jessel you and everybody
else I know I love that I'm like on the
face of that movement she just Rolling
Stone just did a huge um feature on her
she looked fabulous I mean Justice for
Jessel I agree cuz I went into that
season and I was like this and her
husband and this stuff she was trying so
hard with everyone too hard but then I
mean I think it speaks to human nature
and just like kind goodness 100% that we
all ended up rallying together and
rooting for her because she's not a bad
person her biggest crime was just like
wanting to be liked too much and that
made her come off unlikable ironically
but she really she's a nice girl and she
doesn't like come for people and she
doesn't really start stuff she just had
a hard time you know showing us who she
really is yeah and now we see her and we
love and we celebrate her yes and what's
his face pet pet the mileage run thing
to me is so funny cuz my sister Margot
did a mileage run like last December
like a year ago to Boston needed like a
100 more miles like something so small
you couldn't buy it you had to be on a
flight so she's texting us I like hey
guys I'm literally head to the airport
I'm going to Boston I'm like excuse me
we made fun of her and list we still
talk about it my sister every time
Jackie sees my sister Margo she goes I
think I'll go to bus it was the weirdest
thing but I understand it like
I'm a big miles girl myself like I
totally get it but like it was weird
totally weird to Vietnam it's weird it's
weird but it's not a crime no it's not a
crime and they I appreciate them okay so
the new season it's not giving me what I
expect from roony it's fine it's
different it's different I partake I'm
very into gen Alliance you are that was
going to be my next question I'm really
not I don't know why she gives it
nothing like no energy I think I just
like the outfits yes the house and the
house yes that's it I do
like certain elements of her but like as
a housewife
she's not cutting it like we wouldn't
expect this from any she gets special
treatment she 100% does and maybe I like
that Dynamic too for it's up it
is up it's totally up I
think season two will be more
interesting do you think they're going
to keep everyone because Jenna Lions was
just on watch reins live and her tone
and Andy's tone as well was very much
like conclusive like this was a fun
thing that we did really it didn't feel
like there was a lot of potential for a
future and she's very publicly like
alienated herself from the Bravo world
she hates to be like referred to as a
housewife cuz I again she's accomplished
other things but understandable but like
current ERA you're on roony so just lean
in sweet embrace it um that would be I
would be upset if they didn't bring it
back for a season two I think everybody
deserves a season two I'm sorry they
were talking about like just Jenna not
coming back not the entire show it
sounded like Jenna's Journey was over it
might be but I would like to see her
come back yeah it's a good group there's
potential I'll say that there's
potential and I think season one they're
being nice they're doing the thing
they're integrating and then I think
season 2 we'll really see like maybe
some more deeper relationships than
will pop off we have five stories
they're actually all really good stories
sometimes when we wake up it's just like
we're talking about the dumbest and
we just we have to try today we don't
have to try cuz you know things are
popping off and I think it's because I'm
in La so technically I'm like 3 hours
behind I would be recording 9:00 a.m.
New York time so I have more time to
find stories and there's a lot of things
going on so I think I'm going to dive in
if that's okay with you Jackie sham
please so Jackie shimo before we start I
just have one question are you ready for
the past five stories that you need to
know yes today's episode of the toast is
brought to you by Lululemon Lululemon
knows that it's sweater weather we're
all wearing our finest leggings and the
only place to go for leggings we all
also know is Lululemon so they have so
many different fabulous pairs of
leggings whatever your leggings needs
are so if you're like super active girly
running around town jogging and stuff
check out the fast and free leggings
they're powered by the new luux fabric
they provide a weightless on body
sensation and incredible coverage
they're designed for those looking for a
legging that gives them complete freedom
from distractions while running and
jogging they also have the Wonder Trin
leggings which are designed with one of
Lululemon's most Innovative Fabrics the
everlux fabric it's also their fastest
drying fabric because you know you're
working out then you got errands to run
we don't want to be walking around with
a moist crotch it's not nice and
Lululemon totally understands that the
Wonder Trin leggings allow you to work
hard and feel dry so you can effortly
transition from sweat to Street and then
there's the Align leggings which are my
personal favorite I happen to just love
the entire align collection from
Lululemon they're powered by the nulu
fabric they're designed for the person
who wants a lightweight low compression
yoga solution that is also versatile
enough for casual wear cuz I wear
leggings everywhere on the plane to the
grocery store but also obviously when
I'm being active so it giv it gives the
wearer a next too body sensation it's
full freedom of movement and it doesn't
restrict or compress the wearer in any
way it's great for low-intensity
workouts like yoga or like I said just
casual wear which is the best type of
wear in my opinion so get into the
Lululemon leggings it's that time of
year indulge have a good time go to
Lululemon
that's
lemon.com to get into the Lululemon
leggings today's episode is also brought
to you by bowan Branch if your sleep
wasn't an absolute dream then you have
to upgrade to the softest most luxurious
sheets from bowl and Branch these sheets
will immediately change your sleep they
feel very breathable they're luxuriously
soft and they get softer with every wash
they're made from the finest 100%
organic Cottons on Earth and you'll feel
the difference for years to come so if
I'm looking a little raggedy it's
because I'm staying at a hotel and I
didn't have my bowl and brand cheets and
I've been sleeping in my bowl and brand
cheets four years Jackie has too when I
go to Jackie's house I sleep so well
because I know I'm getting the bowling
Branch situation so bowling Branch
products are made differently they are
made so you can sleep better at night
from the rarest 100% organic cotton on
Earth it's free from toxics toxins
synthetic pesticides and harsh chemicals
at every step of their making so the the
sheets that I have and I know that
Jackie has too is the signature hemmed
sheets they're uh come in a bunch of
different designs and colors for every
bedroom style and mattress size and best
of all bowl and branch is giving you a
30 night WorryFree guarantee with free
shipping and Returns on all orders they
also have a gift box their signature
sheets come wrapped and ready in a
beautiful holiday gift box because that
time of year is upon us and if you want
to get ahead of that head to bowling
Branch so give your loved ones a better
night's sleep this holiday season get
20% off your first order plus free
shipping when you use promo code toast
at Bow and branch.com that's bowl and
Branch b o l l n d branch.com promo code
toast it's limited time only and
exclusions do apply so take my advice
cuz I'm kind of an expert on all things
laying down you know that kind of my my
area of expertise and I recommend Bolan
branch and I have never seared you wrong
all right first up Britney's Memoir is
is out okay it's out uh I don't know I
spoke too soon okay whatever it's fine
well there are all these stories coming
out so either the it's out or the
excerpts are out you know they they
pitch the the pr things and she's
talking about the infamous uh head
shaving moment and she's revealing why
she shaved her head in 2007 so after 16
years Britney Spears has finally
revealed why she infamously cut off all
of her hair ahead of her conservatorship
she had said in her book I'd been
eyeballed so much growing up I'd been
looked up and down and had people
telling me that they thought what they
thought of my body since I was a
teenager shaving my head and acting out
were my ways of pushing back however
Britney notes that once her father Jamie
Spears took control of her personal
medical and financial affairs in 2008
she no longer had a say in her
day-to-day life she said I was made to
understand that though those days were
over now I had to grow up my hair get
back into shape I had to go to bed early
and take whatever medication they told
me to take so this isn't necessarily a
bombshell I think we all if we had to
you know about it hard enough we would
have predicted like this was her taking
control of her body when so many things
were out of her control sure sure kind
of like that episode of Lizzie McGuire
where Miranda stops eating and she says
you know my parents are getting divorced
so much is out of control but like the
food and my weight is what I can control
1,00% so I I reson that resonated as a
child of divorce with me I will say that
I have had many moments where I felt
like shaving my own head of course it's
so understandable like I here and there
I'm like if I just had a buzzer I'd pull
a Britney I do often think about
for more so for convenience like if I
was a man oh my God I would be the
happiest man alive totally oh my God
just free flowing in the wind or and I I
just I could never be a woman who
doesn't care about her hair cuz that's
why do I have to be so extreme I don't
have to become a man I just don't have
to do my hair I can't I can't I can't my
hair is my everything it's the most
important thing in my life it is my uh
trouble area you have oh you know what I
love your Saga on your um Instagram
about your hair it's not great you would
never know that your natural hair is so
different from this you would die so you
would die is that your Jewish ancestry
oh yeah and it's popping up hard it's
very curly it is coarse it is Curly it
is similar to a Brill pad mixed with
like a pipe cleaner like if it was
natural and I just like went like this
it would just stay stay up on its own it
would just fully stay so do you do some
sort of treatment for that just a lot of
blow dries just a lot of you know grit
yeah lot of friction lot of friction my
question about Britney Spears um I
understand the Shaving of the head you
know she's taking back her control
what's going on now with the hair that's
an amazing question I do have to assume
it's some sort of aftermath of being
forced to be on drugs you didn't need
for so many years the extensions I'm
well versed in the extension world do
you wear extensions oh yeah oh she does
pounds just pulling or tap in I don't
I've done them all uh currently a sewi
in we we weft H I like that Lots track
got it yes Britney's tracks are always
showing always showing and I'm confused
if there's like a bead if there's a
keratin Bond who who is doing this
that's the thing I don't think anyone's
doing it you know okay if I had to guess
another big bombshell from the book that
just came out is that she opened up that
she and uh Justin Timberlake when they
were together she had gotten an abortion
she said uh he wasn't ready to be a Dad
wow yeah okay this is news to me I did
not hear this so I think they're really
Limited in how they can promote
Britney's book because she's not in any
sort of condition to do a sit down
interview or go on the podcast rounds
she not going to do smartless no so did
you see that they're releasing
Crossroads in theaters they re releasing
it no isn't that like as a promotional
thing for her book that is genius and so
I guess they're now releasing STS cuz
they have to build hype for it but they
really can't they can't send her on the
road and Michelle Williams from um
everything I think of her from the
greatest showman she Dawson's Creek yeah
sure she is um reading the audio book
dawon's Creek I have no JW's
Creek is another show that like similar
to Gilmore Girls like is so my
demographic in my era went completely
over my head I never got into it to
woodsy for me I I do think I would like
Gilmore Girls and I me and Ben started
to watch it like a year ago we watched
the first episode and it cut to the
theme song and Ben started singing it
I'm like how the do you know this
song He's like I used to watch a show a
lot with my sister I'm like oh okay
freak like you he knew everything
already I have never seen an episode I
had seen the first episode and I'm sure
it's good but I just I no 7 heaven it's
no 7th heav and I didn't stick with it
yeah it didn't pull you in it didn't but
um so they're do Michelle Williams is
doing the audio book for it because I
guess Brittney also can't like you know
sit down I recorded an Audi book it's
actually like a lot of work and it's
horrible like every time you
mispronounce one word to start from the
beginning it's horrible why does
Michelle Williams need that gig why does
Michelle Williams need that gig how do
Michelle Williams and Britney Spears
know one another is that just like an LA
thing I maybe it makes no sense maybe
they came up at the same time maybe
another thing about the book that I just
saw is that Christina Aguilera was on
Jimmy Kimmel and Jimmy Kimmel asked if
she thinks she's going to be in the book
and she was like really weird about it
making it seem like she hopes she's not
because if it's in there like whatever's
going to be in there wouldn't be good oh
I love that she was like really feeling
feeling awkward and Jimmy like wasn't
letting it go even though I mean this is
unpopular to say Britney Spears makes me
a little nervous for sure like we're not
supposed to say no I think you can
people get really upset about the
ritning spears of it all it's a it's a
definitely a very delicate corner of the
internet and I I have never been a part
of the free Britney movement like I
believed in her freedom I thought it was
bad you know but like a little
supervision is okay right no well so now
I I think what we're seeing is like when
she had was put into a conservatorship
um maybe she wasn't a good candidate for
it but the weing now like is actually
the candate for conserv but she has so
many Bad actors around her who could you
possi trust with that sort of power if
you couldn't even trust her own father I
will say that it gives me Solace that
she still has her travertine floors and
not marble cuz it's a little slick well
and she's like always dancing around and
sweating she could slip and crack her
fracture her skull like but travertine
has a grip I know you're remodeling your
house so you know what travertine is
what the is travertin
travertin is like I'm really fixated on
this your house is beautiful by the way
I love I love all the content thank you
so much travertine is that like beigy
bread colored kind of porous tile got it
Natural Stone so it's not slippery it's
not it has some grit to it got it okay
it's it's good if you have like children
running around got it so it's not like
that shiny marble or tile yes I
understand okay very is good that's very
safe maybe that's why she's always
dancing in that particular room I think
so it's a good landing pad for her I
would prefer a carpet that makes me feel
a little bit better I see that her
living room has a a sunken in living
room because there's two steps that's
dangerous too very dangerous there's
actually been like a lot of Britney news
her oldest son also just turned 18 so
Kevin fedline is not qualified for um
child support anymore for that first kid
wow yeah they still have the other one
but both you're a real
journalist over there Jesus Christ
really not actually and I'm not even he
like invested in the Britney movement my
younger sister margar was like obsessed
with Britney I I wasn't like a big
Britney girl I just know because like I
do the podcast and it's like really sad
but it also was very confusing it's
super confusing because we all were like
free Britney free Britney free Britney
and then we freed her and we were like
oh my God yikes yeah and so now
seriously like as from a a human
perspective what do we do now kind of
nothing right I guess we just buy the
book in support totally cuz I think she
also I'm when it comes to Britney my the
most interesting part for me is her
finances I'm cuz I don't think she has a
lot I don't think so either and like
where did that money go and like so many
people have their pockets in her hands I
mean in her hands in their Pock oh my
God I can't speak had their
hands in her Pockets yeah for so many
years that when she got out I think
there was a lot less money and now she
it's been like a year two years I don't
even know she doesn't work right she
takes a lot of trips on private jets she
has a big house like those things that
up 100% security hopefully that
crossroads reboot brings some money in
hopefully I'll be there 100% that that
movie left an indelible mark on me I've
started crimping my hair recently and
back to your roots yeah exactly I'm
regressing and I feel like maybe that is
unintentionally inspired by CrossRoads
Britney didn't she have somewhat of a
crimp towards the end toward when she
got more like edgy and started
performing in those
clubs she did sort of embrace like the
inner edgy Queen and she just kind of
let it and then she started dating that
murderer right turned her away from her
house in Arizona that movie is amazing
my entire First comedy special is about
that movie I absolutely love that movie
and there's so many interesting like
references pop culture references from
that movie of course Kim catrell Taran
Manning Zoe salana I mean I mean of
course Britney Spears it's it should be
studied it's the best movie I have not
seen it in so long and I'm going to
rewatch it I would totally we should go
to the theaters and see it I would love
to all right are you ready for our next
story some Housewives news like these
are two people who aren't a part of the
house Housewives Universe anymore whom I
would literally lay my life out on the
line for like I am obsessed with the
Beerman did you watch Don't Be Tardy of
course I did transfixed for the Beerman
that was in my opinion up there with the
greatest of greats in terms of family
like I think of it as just as good as
Keeping Up with the Kardashians like
family reality TV shows they were
grossly
underaredsky season when they were kind
of like scrambling for viewership and
they took an RV and like went obsessed
with the Red Cups love it the Red Cups
and now in hindsight so much of what we
saw on that show which we thought was
funny like Kim drinking a lot and
gambling a lot and like pulling over the
RV to go to this like turn reservation
where they could go gambling and she was
at the slots all of that was funny but
now it's evidence right they are I think
getting divorced what is going on they
were and then they weren't and I forgot
where we left off I think think we left
off that they weren't right I thought
maybe they were reconciling or they
called off the divorce she needed to go
to a facility of some sort and then
there was like d like a body cam footage
when the police came into their home to
break up like a domestic dispute yeah
and now they are selling their iconic
Georgia Mansion for $6 million on the
heels of their financial wo so in
similar to Britney these were two people
whose financial situation I was
constantly thinking about every day the
neap Porte deliver
The Bangles the bangal the Christmas
tree decorations that was like
Kardashian level oh yeah cars the cars
for the kids too it was wasn't adding up
the math wasn't mathing no so now
they're selling their home the estranged
couple according to page six so I guess
they aren't together they have been
living together amid their divorce
listed the two story seven-bedroom 11b
brick and stone estate on Monday and
almost double what it was listed for
earlier this month so the property was
built you know you're into real estate
now tell me if you think this is like a
fair situ
the property was built in 2008 features
a heated pool five fireplaces a sixc car
garage a full back in-law suite a
separated off pair Suite A circular
driveway a Chef's kitchen and an
oversized Island a full bar an oversized
Island get out okay a full-size bar a
wine seller multiple walk-in closets an
elevator a finished basement an inground
trampoline a Billiards room an arcade
room a movie theater and a gym with
private massage room how many square
feet it actually did not say cuz you
know that's important it you know what
it looks like a big mansion but when you
look at it a lot of it is garage I think
it's important to not so they bought it
in 2012 for $880,000 I know this that's
insane okay I know this because I've
been crunching numbers okay so if they
bought it in what when did you say 2007
2008 2008 okay so that's like roughly
what 16 almost years ago 15 years ago
for8 $880,000
and he was working he was uh playing
football at the time and she was very
much so employed yes no they were
financially well back then so if they
put the down payment let's call it 25%
they needed to come up with let's be
generous generous Grand okay that that
means they only would owe $600
something, on the house over the last 15
years 15 years you don't need 18 matte
black G wagons 84 cardier love bracelets
you need to pay your mortgage no it's
true and you know what there was a high
likelihood that they could have bought
the house for cash right if he was in
the NFL she was probably liquid from
like Instagram and Real Housewives yeah
800 they could have together come up
with under a million dollars for sure
and I wouldn't be surprised so now I
mean how did they get the house so cheap
and wasn't there a whole storyline on
real house of Atlanta that she rented
her house yes but that's true they
called the cops on the landlord yes but
then they were buying the house they
were leasing to buy I don't really know
that feels slippery to me to me this
whole situation is Housewives at its
finest 100% like a mansion that nobody
knows where it came from she shé the
cops are showing up I will say that also
was one of my absolute favorite moments
in Real Housewives of Atlanta when
everyone's homes were like up for
criticism and everyone's house the more
Manor chatau by shereé when everyone's
house had a name doormat people were
giving the doormat baseboard not FSH
basins to me that was Peak comedy like
it really was it's so Niche and it's so
petty and it makes me so happy like the
real estate shaming but I just want to
say so they're selling this house for $6
million they bought it for $880 they
won't get 66 million no and two months
ago they were were listing it for 3
million that no no I'm not familiar with
like the housing market in Georgia I'm
pretty sure it doesn't double in a month
no it doesn't double in a month but but
they this was a good investment for them
like they should make money on this
house unless they owe so much on it
they're not going to make anything right
and it's just going to be collected by
the cour I don't own a house so I'm like
very critical of people's you know
finances and mortgages when I myself am
a renter um but I'm just that's the
beauty of this whole situation you know
I'm just like young young thin fruitful
young young girls like don't buy houses
you drink aan smoothies exactly I love
these two like I will be mourning the
loss of this marriage for years to come
I was shocked
sh I was devastated yeah no do you
remember Express mile Atlanta do you
have any idea what I'm talking about no
I don't it was a teeth whitening company
that like the beans were always Hawking
yep I to me the mystery uhhuh behind
that whole company haunts me to this day
yeah like where did they go what
happened and like how many people's
teeth fell out like I just I know what
were they just like it was a light it
was like an LED light that you like
shove in your mouth with some bleach and
they were with bleach they were always
Hawking that on Instagram and what
happened to like the skin care and the
beauty boxes and the robes and the robes
yeah they had a few they had kids
clothing they had kids clothing it
wasn't for lack of trying they had an
entrepreneurial Spirit yeah but
something's got to stick yeah no and
honestly I think things like for the
family really went downhill when Croy
left the NFL yeah like he was Leto from
he played in Atlanta forever and he was
like loved there and he wasn't amazing
but he was like a good steady player
sure and then he got transferred
whatever it's called traded to the bills
in Buffalo look at us talking Sports the
family didn't go with him they let him
go to Buffalo by himself and they're
like well let's see if this works out
and they dropped him so he just came
back to Atlanta so it was a good thing
they didn't move yeah that was a dark
time for the family and I do think it
was beginning of the end yeah I think so
I think you're right okay our next story
are uh two people I'm just forced to
keep talking about I every piece of
information I receive about Jada and
Will Smith is against my will like I
don't go searching for this I know but I
will say I chose this as a story and
then on my way here I was scrolling Tik
Tok and I saw that she was on a podcast
and I think a lot of the new stories
that have come out this last week are
headlines from that podcast and she was
crying crying crying no days off for
Jada I I want to say like I actually
felt bad for her oh really even though
I'm so fatigued by this story like it
didn't feel I know she's like a an
actress by trade it didn't feel like she
was acting but apparently they've been
separated for seven years so she has a
book coming out so she's on a press tour
and that's why we're still every day
it's you know more J more will so on
paper Jada pinkin and Will Smith have
been a Hollywood power couple for nearly
25 years but in real life they
apparently have haven't been an actual
couple since
2016 Jada told this to hodat they did
like a today show segment excuse me dat
line so in a preview for that the
actress confirmed that she and Smith
have been living completely separate
lives for seven years they are still
married but not romantically involved
here's the exchange with Hoda Hoda says
it was not a divorce on paper right mhm
but was a divorce Jada divorce oh whoa
so asked what caused the M marriage to
fracture she didn't answer explicitly
but she does say that when Chris Rock
stormed the stage and will said leave my
wife's name out your mouth she
was shocked quote really shocked to hear
Smith refer to her as his wife
considering they hadn't called each
other husband and wife in a very long
time but they're there as a couple yeah
keeping up appearances why are you there
with him if you're not affil if you're
not identifying as his wife even just
for the sake of but seven years she had
that show table talk where she talked
about marriage and family she had the
entanglement with that other guy August
so was all that a lie like I'm so
confused is a foundation built on
now we don't trust Jada now we
don't trust the red table no theed table
was a place for people to come together
oh I watched when Jordan Woods was on I
watched I watched when Olivia Jade was
on same there was a lot of iconic pop
culture moments and then they franchised
the show Gloria estfan and her family
her mother and her daughter got their
own red table talk is it still going no
because Facebook watch as a network has
been cancelled okay got it but they
tried and I felt like we I feel we've
all been duped by the red table cuz
every every time there was a problem
with the with the Smith family they took
it to the table right and it was like a
place of honesty and transparency but
you didn't want to say that you're not
together for seven years that's kind of
a big one to hide J and I'm just
fatigued I'm exhausted by these people
like it's so not a story it's a story
that never ends never and I hate me and
Jackie say this a lot like when
celebrities have multiple documentaries
yeah and they say like you know the last
documentary that wasn't the real me like
I wasn't I hate when people like do
something and it's like this is the
truth this is who I am and then years
later they're like actually no this is
my truth now we don't trust you you're
abusing consumerism you are you are
abusing using
consumerism and that's how I feel here
same couldn't agree more and her book
um is out and everyone go get a copy I
think this is just the beginning right
of stuff we're going to hear but this
was probably the
biggest that's pretty wild it's also
really wild that they cannot be spoken
about without people bringing up the
slap can I tell you something please
Andrew my husband's studio is shares a
property line with the Smith home wow
yeah and when all this was going
down there was helicopters circling and
he couldn't even like record because of
the sounds blah blah blah a producer's
nightmare H truly meanwhile pop star at
home couldn't you know Finagle a song
for me but that's okay um and they live
so close and we I have never ever seen
Jada or will like they don't leave their
little compound is it huge yes I
wouldn't leave it either they never
leave I would you never see them com
coming you never see them leaving I
what's so funny is that whenever they
the family is in the Press which is a
lot there's a new wave of people who are
just now putting together that their
children's being their children being
named Willow and and Jaden uhuh is like
a extrapolated version of will Jada
Willow and Jaden yeah people don't know
that that's very dumb how do people not
know that I can't lie like I didn't know
I didn't know that
either like people are so dumb I
appreciate your honesty yeah true
honestly these are two people I wish
well I just really wish I didn't have to
hear about it like there's a certain
point with celebrity and where you get
to overexposure and I feel like we got
there a really long time ago yeah oh
we're done with the entanglement thing
and the red table to me that was like
this is far too much feel free to keep
this to yourself like we we respect your
privacy please keep it private yeah keep
it private they refuse it's so
interesting when people reach that level
of success wouldn't the ultimate form of
luxury be dimming the lights closing the
curtains like they don't need she they
are they don't need money like she her
Memoir will do well she doesn't need to
bleed out for it they're good take the
day off take the year off so when people
are out here doing the most and they
like need the money to pay their rent I
respect it yeah tap dance honey but if
you're overexposing yourself with
millions and millions and millions in
the bank hundreds of millions yeah
there's no excuse for that broken energy
broken energy because this is a business
I get that sure I respect it you don't
need this no you don't need the
relevance you don't need the Kish and
honestly I feel like it work it works
against her because every time people
are like people get so fatigued by it
they're like enough are they still
scientologists were they I believe
so I believe so oh unconfirmed allegedly
what do I know I believe so I have a lot
of thoughts on Scientology so do I what
are your thoughts not a fan no of course
not I'm following the Saga so it's so
dumb but this is like my corner of the
internet okay so there was a girl on Tik
Tok who like ate weird foods and like
she blew up because everybody was like
what the are you eating and then of
course likeability is a prison they
found out she's a Scientologist there
you go and now it's like all the the
love she had received is being you know
sent in equal amounts of hate right and
I actually feel bad for her but she is a
Scientologist I mean it's kind of
warranted it's just crazy when when
people who aren't celebrities are
scientologists I I can't believe it how
do you get involved maybe you're like
trying to meet so I I don't understand I
really you have to be in a very dark
place who we like the most obviously we
know Tom Cruz Tom Cruz we know formerly
Leah reminy uh what's a moss of
Elizabeth Moss from um handmaid's tail
that's a shocker and in theory I it's
hard for me because I love her in theory
as an actress yes but now I don't trust
her I can't support it I can't support
her it's so terrible and toxic when you
love someone and then you find out
they're a Scientologist I'm out I just
found out someone was a Scientologist
but you know what I need to start
googling things before I say them so let
me just
I just well John Travolta of course that
he's also like a classic one I feel like
a lot of the the backlash against
Scientology falls on the hands of Tom
Cruz and John Travolta yes yeah there
were rumors okay that Khloe feeman from
SNL was in Scientology that would ruin
my life but but not confirmed and this
article from
MSN says maybe she's not I hope not if
she is she needs to keep she suspected
it's crazy how it's like an
investigation a suspected she's
suspected to be a second generation
Scientologist meaning she was born into
the church I thought she was Jewish I
did too findan I would hope so I would
hope so oh that's it's crazy good
Scientology is something I'll like never
I I'll never not watch a documentary
about me too and I still don't get it me
neither like the levels the clear the
clear what what do you mean clear the
clear what does that mean when I go um
on the last two times I've gone on tour
I go to the Tampa area okay and there's
a um a fabulous theater there in clear
waterer okay that I've played at twice
that's literally around the corner from
the Scientology headquarters Scientology
is headquartered in Clearwater Florida
the first time I went which was in 2018
there was like a couple people on the
street walking around in like flight
attendant uniforms and I was like what's
that and people were like oh Scientology
is based here it's really weird I came
back a few years later the town is
completely
completely desolate there are no people
in town except the people who walk
around in those uniforms it's insane
both times I went I left that night it's
so freaky and what's with the cruise
ship I what goes on like what's with the
cruise ship I don't know was like a
carnival cruise with Scientology I don't
get it the levels the clear the elron
hubard of it all so weird it's
fascinating I know I'm like completely
confused and transfixed like I could
understand cuz I'm like a person who's
deeply um like I'm easily influence and
if I was you know becoming famous and
living in LA and all the other famous
cool skinny people were doing this thing
like I could could totally see myself
getting swept up and becoming like the
number one Scientologist listen I bought
18 different Merit eyeshadows yesterday
because I saw them on Tik Tok I love
Merit really good yeah really nice very
blendable okay so I understand being
easily influenced and like taken in and
you don't have friends and come here and
your life will be better you'll be you
know dating Tom Cruz right sure sure but
little something's not right no and that
was such an interesting part of Stacey
scher's first book is that her and Jax
like almost joined Scientology when they
first were living in LA and they were
really young so funny imagine Stacey a
Scientologist I truly could see it I can
see it all right our next story she
would she would love that our next story
is uh Lance Bass related were you an
insync or a backst street boy ftic you
know what I was a Spice Girls person
like you supported women in the industry
supporting women ex what are your
thoughts on the the ideology of women
supporting women I feel like women that
feel the need to P like I feel like that
whole notion and making that your brand
in public means you probably don't
support women and are you a woman who
unequivocally supports other women me
neither no like are you a are you
a Scientologist yeah like there are
levels okay I don't care if you got a
vagina or a penis 100% this if you're
I don't with you this
blanket requirement to support people
because they're women like that's never
going to be me cuz I've met some women
and I always say I ain't Marching for
you no like I I need to know you
before I support you I don't just give
away support yeah that's ridiculous
ridiculous I just want to make sure
we're on the same yeah yeah totally
today's episode of the toast is brought
to you by drizzly drizzly is the go-to
app for drink delivery drizly is the
most convenient way to get beer Wine and
Spirits delivered to your doorstep right
when you want it one thing about me I
love delivery if something's coming to
my house that's a joy that's a gift from
God and we should be thankful thank you
drizzly their tled experience lets you
find the perfect drink for the perfect
occasion no matter what it is you'll
save time by shopping a huge selection
of drinks from wherever you are it's
also a great way to discover new brands
I find myself like ordering random stuff
I've never seen in a store and loving it
and finding new brands that I love so
it's also great for gifting if you're
showing up for someone's house uh for a
dinner party and you forgot something
you know the day of you can get it
delivered and then you look like a
really nice house guest even though
you're a thoughtless
Pig uh we uh love to plan ahead with
gift giving and the option on drizzly
where you can schedule ahead a delivery
and Order ahead is so so fabulous so
download the drizzly app today or go to
drizly.com that's d r Iz l.com
and use code toast to receive $5 off or
a $0 delivery free off your next order
must be 21 or older not valid in all
states codes cannot be combined with any
other offers not valid at all retailers
code expires November 10th 2023 11:59
p.m. Eastern Standard Time thank you
drizzly for sponsoring today's episode
that's a really exciting new sponsor I
use drizzly all the time big fan of it
in a lot of cities you can get Spritz on
drizzly which we love so thank you
drizzly excited to be partnering with
drizzly today's episode is also brought
to you by the farmers dog you know one
thing about as Jax and I is the the love
and care that we put into our strice
brothers is is of utmost importance and
I know a lot of you guys feel the same
so when it comes to giving them food we
want the best right we want fresh
healthy dog food and that's what the
farmer's dog is they make and deliver
fresh healthy dog food it's developed by
vets it's nutritionally balanced and
it's made from real healthy ingredients
to human food safety standards it's the
best option for dogs at all life stages
because it's not kibble it's not caned
goo it's just real healthy food
traditional dry and wet dog food options
are highly process and can use much
lower quality ingredients than they
claim to they are extremely difficult to
also portion accurately once you switch
over to the farmer's dog you will find
enormous benefits for your dog's health
for me specifically I found that Theo's
breath was so much better that was like
a a kind of really gross thing that he
had but also I knew it wasn't normal his
breath is like good dog breath he's
making more consistent poops his coat is
really shiny he's just got a lot of
energy and if you have an older dog you
will notice a lot of benefits from
switching to fresh healthy dog food at
the farmer's dog it doesn't matter if
your dog is young or old it's always the
right time to begin investing in their
health they'll help you live a more
healthy happy and full years together
with your strice brethren that means
more magical moments with your dog but
no act actual oh my God am I okay no
actual magic is required so get 50% off
your first box of fresh healthy food at
thefarmersdog.com toast plus you'll get
free shipping just go to
thefarmersdog.com toast that's only uh
free shipping and 50% off your first box
when you go to
thefarmersdog.com toast for 50% off your
first box and free shipping so Lance
Bass is making news because he was at a
football game they put him on the
Jumbotron whatever the it's called
and he had a sign he made a sign I guess
he made it at home with a piece of paper
little marker little marker and it wrote
uh not Taylor Swift so when they put him
on the screen I don't think anybody
thought it was going to be Taylor Swift
he held up his homemade sign that said
not Taylor Swift he workshopped that so
hard yeah it's a little like try hard
it's just it's it's so sad on so many
levels and I would like to Deep dive it
yeah the preparation the preparation is
really where you lose it okay so you
like went to a CVS or a Michaels got a
little cardboard thing a Sharpie got a
Sharpie maybe some glitter glue I'm not
trying to stereotype I'm just saying
there's probably some glitter glue and
then thought what would be funny if they
happen to put me on the screen because
I'm Lance Bass right and then he
workshopped the joke workshopped the bit
probably asked a friend asked his
husband they coign on the sentiment then
he packed the poster so true in
like a merse the level of prep is
disarming and then just waited looking
at the screen foaming at the mouth to
hold up that poster and like really land
the plane terrible yeah it it requires
too much prep had he been on the screen
and been like where's tlor Swift or like
M something sure cute and funny the
level of prep is concerning here dismal
and it just like this is what he wanted
this page six article and and he got it
so I guess that's good and we're talking
about it I did want to bring it up
because I'm dying to know what your
thoughts on Taylor Swift in general are
and then as a you know current woman in
music yeah right but with Travis and
everything but just for At a Glance what
are your thoughts on Taylor Swift okay
so I will say that um I'm a newfound
Swifty love probably in the past like
couple years I've really found um a deep
appreciation for her songwriting skills
as a songwriter yourself as a songwriter
myself exactly and I do think that she
is probably the greatest pop star of all
time love agree it's just the truth it's
the truth and you don't have to love the
music or you don't have to love her
whole environment Community whatever you
don't have to co-sign on that but facts
are facts you have to respect it you
have to respect it and she is the
greatest to ever do it agree did you go
to the eror tore I did not oh you missed
out I was like in diapers yeah oh right
duh sorry way more important I like
hemorrhaging so I couldn't go did you go
to Beyonce I so you go to a concert um I
went to The 1975 yes you did I did and
what were your thoughts when he was
dating Taylor very briefly I liked it
you did yes I understand that um maybe
to the naked eye he's problematic in
nature but I think that that's
intentional and it's actually not
straightforward problematic I think it's
it's art I think it's like performance
art it's performance art but he's on the
right side of History I think so most of
the time yeah and I just think he's very
hot Okay so like I'm lost in like a
gerby little way so that's her aesthetic
like skinny gery Brits and so now it's
so exciting for her jacked no he's not I
know but like Travis okay now yeah what
are your thoughts no no he looks like
someone that puts chips on a sandwich
definitely does and like eats like
Cheetos and always has on the fingers I
do not think he's hot hot that might be
the hottest take you've ever had because
I do not think he's hot Nothing in life
is guaranteed but like Travis Kelsey
being hot hot is like a guarantee first
of all let me just like build my case he
had a reality dating show on the E
network I just recently rewatched it
okay Sahara vagina it was amazing number
two he did by the way in his defense
recently speak on it he said um he was a
rookie in the NFL he got paid a lot of
money he was so excited he ran through
all of his money and he had no money
okay do porn I don't care okay that
would be better I do only fans I don't
care y so I don't love that strike one
strike two the fa hair and designer
track
suits to me I I actually I hear you I
like it I think it's like a part of his
like goofball Vibe he's like this Rich
talented goofball okay he was wearing a
red Seline tracksuit like uh Jane Lynch
from GLE very it's giving Sue Sylvester
it was giving Sue Sylvester and I'm just
not in to like that white jock guy I
understand it's re it's like I can just
tell he loves loves a sub sandwich with
like and he puts barbecue chips on it no
I do want to say like you bringing up
sandwiches like I I I get it and I love
sandwiches no I know what you mean he
definitely like I'll go to a local
Italian deli and get weird with
sandwich he definitely celebrates like
$5 foot long season Jimmy John's yeah no
I get it I get it but I'm shocked that
you don't find him attractive I do not
find him attractive at all but you find
Matty Healey attractive I do you're
weird I'm disgusting disgusting
like that makes no sense that's
completely backwards I know but there's
something about I don't know I can't
describe it okay it's like a raw feral
energy no I understand I understand I
just I don't know why I just expected
you to like hate Taylor Swift well I I
wasn't in love with Taylor Swift
probably a few years ago I was just like
I don't get it it's overhyped and then
it clicked for me what particular piece
of music was it that did that for you um
you know I really love lover I love that
song wow I feel like not a lot of people
became swifties because of lover I think
in the grand scheme of her discography
it wasn't a flop by any means 1989 is
ridiculously incredible it's the
greatest work of Po it's the greatest
modern pop work of art I totally agree
and people didn't like reputation I
with reputation pretty hard I
liked reputation I like everything she
does so when I like something more
reputation was not my favorite but by no
means did I dislike it it just wasn't at
the top of my list and then when I was
pregnant I never listened to the
10minute version Oh of all too well and
I was going to the camel Outlets to a
Restoration Hardware Outlet to like look
for a discount crib did you find one no
didn't and I put it on and I remember
going down the incline and I was crying
just headed to Restoration I mean what a
beautiful moment in time it's beautiful
were you you were pregnant at the time
like so and like regretting it yeah yeah
yeah yeah no that's a tough place to be
in yeah I mean just thinking about it
gets me Misty and I was like why am I
trying to be cool and be a raran I think
that was what was happening with me I
love that you can own that I think I've
definitely I've definitely been there
with things before where like everybody
likes something so I just immediately
dislike it and then I'm only denying
myself that pleasure right things are
popular for a reason right exactly that
happens to me all the time like with
reading really yeah you read that's
adorable I read so much will you send me
some books cuz I need to start reading
cuz it's getting a little up here okay
I'm going to tell you something that
like people who don't read don't realize
and it's going to blow your mind okay a
lot of the books that like women our age
read and that books that go viral and
books that everyone are talking about
are literally pornography yeah no I'm
down so I'll send if you want some it's
called smut okay what does that stand
for I can never remember it's like
sexually manipulating under text or
something I don't know great smut just
means like a book is you know a romance
novel where people be you know
skanky H and there are there are smut
books that are like some of the most
incredible books you've ever read and
they also happen to be pornographic send
them I have a list it's kind of I've
gotten a few girls into it and like they
come to me for recommendations and and
so we start easy the the the gateway
drug to smut is this book called it
happen one summer okay I do believe it's
being made into a movie um start with
that okay and then come to me and tell
me you're not a changed woman after you
read that book I like psychological
Thriller porny okay so you would love an
author called Freedom mcfaden okay she
herself is a psychologist and she writes
short stories for her patients and she
started publishing them on Amazon Kindle
and she became I don't even know if
she's a psychologist anymore she's the
like one of the biggest authors in the
world now perfect I want women snapping
oh oh my God yeah I feel like a lot of
your interests would line up with
different book genres I think so you
should get into reading I'm going to
start start it happened once woman of
the world over here you're seriously and
I think um Jackie really like always
read but I think with like breastfeeding
and like motherhood things like you have
pockets of time where you just like
laying you don't want to be on your
phone cuz a baby's sleeping sure reading
is perfect for that I feel like that's
like my new Frontiers being someone that
reads no and then you similar with the
arance smothie you become morally
Superior right can you imagine you saw
me outside with my child reading a book
reading and then the next time like you
have someone on your podcast and they
don't read like you can feel better than
that person like I was reading this book
last night right no and I was I was
reading this book last night oh my God
this could be good for me no and
honestly it's really it's actually very
good for like your mental health like
just to not be on your phone all the
time yeah I still am on my phone all the
time just to take little breaks I love
it's good so speaking of um the unwell
our fifth and final story is about Tom
sandal Jackie where were you during the
Scandal I know exactly where I was okay
I was at hnut in calabases that's where
the Kardashians get their salads right
that's where they get their salads that
they Shake yes so I got an iced tea
there and then I went to the east coast
Bagel next door cuz I was dying for a
bagel with locks shmir I'm starving also
pregnant and like you're not supposed to
eat locks while you're pregnant I could
I not giving a about any of those
roles didn't give a I got a lock
shme I was eating my bagel outside I got
a text message Panic text message I
believe it was from Heather McMahon
actually and it was like a
911 just page six screenshot I was so
vamped that I went to throw away my
bagel I threw away my purse oh in a
disgusting trash can filled with cream
cheese a PGA oh did you fish it off of
course I did I like godam okay it's okay
it's a little rough but it's okay that's
funny I was just I was like I got to I
got to get to my car I got to get on my
phone I got to call I got to make calls
like I was sweating panicking out of
sorts out of sorts picked up the purse
get in the car start phoning everybody I
know with a pulse I was I was shaken
yeah I was traumatized that wormy little
it was insane H so to the point you
know when you're reading something I
feel like we all experienc when you're
reading something I saw it because James
posted a screenshot of the page six
saying the second it came out and being
like what the he posted it in his
feed and I follow him on Instagram and I
was with Jackie and I was like you know
when you read words and they don't
process yes like you know what the word
says but you don't know what the word
means yes I was like wait
Tom affair with Raquel for nine months
or how I was like it was just not adding
it wasn't making sense it wasn't
Computing for me no so now in all this
has happened I'm sure you know Tom
sandal is on this FX show that actually
a lot of people really like it's called
Special Forces where they take like it's
kind of like I'm a celebrity get me out
of here Beverly Mitchell was on it she
was on Special Forces or I'm a celebrity
to get me out of here I don't know okay
I think Special Forces I'm a celebrity
get me out of here was like the original
version where they like took a bunch of
reality stars Heidi and Spencer were on
it and they threw them in the woods and
gave them like nothing to survive so
funny and so um it's this show where
reality stars and different people JoJo
SE well was on it they go through like
army training like the like SEAL Team
Six like how far could you make it going
through like the worst of the worst army
training and Tom sandal is on it and
obviously everyone's talking about that
but they're talking about a particular
moment from this week's episode where
he's crying while taking a dump I mean
nothing makes more sense the vanderp
rule star recovers from an emotional
challenge in Monday's episode by crying
while pooping he said dude that was so
intense man he says in page six
exclusive preview while seated in an
ouse knowing that his castmate Bode
Miller is standing nearby to listen he
said I'm laughing and crying at the same
time while trying to I feel so
defeated out there while the nature of
the the challenge is unknown the Alpine
ski racer consoles the Bravo Ley by
saying that such a reaction was the
whole point of it so he lets the camera
in here I'll give you a visual he's
quite literally screaming crying
sweating throwing up on the toilet
disgusting so he lets the camera into
the ouse and has this kind of breakdown
on camera while and I'd love to
get your take on that Jackie um is your
full name Jacqueline yes it is how's it
spelled uh j a l y n okay I would just
like to go on record and say that I
think Tom sand ofal is the biggest
roaming the Western Hemisphere and I
want to be very clear that is not
derogatory towards women it's not I
don't it is uh derived from Puss
anamalous which means cowardly the more
you know she reads Latin I don't know
did you just make that up I might have
but I don't think so I feel like I
researched this drunk one night when
someone was like don't call men
because that's rude to our gender and
I'm like I will tear your ass up yeah I
tear your up I will tear your
up okay mine's been torn up yours
is about to get torn up oh how are you
healing pretty good okay good pretty
good yes yeah for real I was like out of
diapers in a week and a half look at you
I put a thong on okay week two I've
never had a child and I still refuse to
put a thong on it it was a bad decision
that that's Brave it was a bad decision
almost as Brave as Tom sandal so brave
on the toilet so I feel like
we've definitely hit a point cuz I think
Tom sandal hasn't always will be like a
very thirsty person and do anything for
fame but there was probably a point in
his life where he wouldn't have
considered you know being filmed while
taking a but I think things are so
dire for him he needs you know the
world's back on his side that he agreed
to do this it's it's a sign he's just
he's such an interesting character
because on one hand he's so vulnerable
and open and
alistic and you know giving and loving
and artsy but he's also the dumbest
person on television
yeah like he we could spin it and
repackage it in any way that you know we
that we see fit but he's a dumb
yeah he's a wormy dumb and I do not
like him no I don't think that's a crazy
thing to say I do not like him either
and I actually feel like now that we're
out of it were heighten emotions were so
heightened when we were all going
through Scandal and watching the show
and everything on social media and now
that we're out of it I I do feel still
like this deep hatred for Tom sandal but
I feel this IM sadness for Raquel me too
I think of her as like a victim in all
of this I even though she was like the
perpetrator absolutely but the beating
that she took yeah un it was unfair from
everyone from everybody they should all
be minorly ashamed of themselves I agree
like they took it too far towards the
end it was way too far it was
uncomfortable to watch they were
basically telling her at the reunion
like to kill herself exactly you're a
worthless human being nobody here likes
you ugly yeah like just the worst things
you can say to someone disgusting so and
she's not was not able to benefit from
this major Scandal whatsoever like Tom
sanal is on this show he is a podcast
and he's doing a lot of things I believe
he was just also on the mask singer oh
God Ariana of course is the media
darling of the universe she has every
brand duracel Bloomingdales everything
and Raquel is just at this facility and
trying to keep her mental sanity in
check obviously what she did is wrong
wrong and you know morally not in line
however the punishment that she had to
endure did not fin it fit the crime
crime completely agree yeah it was hard
to watch yeah so now I look back on the
scan of all time with like just kind of
this like Eerie sadness I know it feels
like dark and haunting yeah it's not fun
it it's not fun it was like kind of fun
when we were in it and now it's like
damn no because there was it was at
someone's expense exactly and good
people and not the person who deserved
it in my opinion no totally agree Jackie
shim you absolutely crushed the fast
five stories I did I absolutely loved
podcasting with you I can't wait to do
it again me too and if anybody liked
what they heard here check out the
Bible also can you please bring back
Mind Body no soul my God The Little
Engine That Couldn't it was it's my best
work so that was like a meditative
podcast of course in an ironic shim way
yeah satirical guided meditations the
title was incredible Mind Body no soul I
just burnt out too quickly I I bit off
more than I could chew I like that it
exists that we can always go back to it
and reference it and it's kind of funny
that it was a flop was it um kind of
it's so important Viola Davis said like
you have to flop oh I'm in my flop era
right now you have to flop because you
can't Thrive unless you flopped and
you'll never know when you're doing well
if you don't know when when you've done
bad yeah I'm flipping and flopping all
over the place I like it it feels good
it's refreshing so weekly podcast did
you take any time off from your podcast
after birth no a woman in business I
didn't I pre- recorded So I wasn't
putting out live episodes but I think I
only pre-recorded for 2 weeks and I was
back on it that's insane yeah it's like
therapy you know it's fun of course so
check out the Bible follow Jackie
on Instagram for all her motherhood
things it's not it's not your regular
motherhood content no it is not there's
a lot of crying not for the easily
offended not for the easily offended I
think that should be today's episode
title disclaimer yeah thank you so much
for being here thank you and thank you
everyone for listening to the toast and
londay Morning Show where we deliver the
past five stories you need to know every
Monday Friday on YouTube so every
watching us on YouTube please feel free
to subscribe and give this video a
thumbs up we're also available as
podcast anywhere podcast can be found at
Spotify public radio radio cast box all
the places we listen to podcast find us
the to Five Star but a beautiful
standing and wickedly talented we are
hope you have an amazing day and we'll
see you tomorrow bye that was very
impressive thank
you